As I mentioned before, we actually solved this equation for the values of u.
But we're really interested in the values of x. We want the values that make
our original equation true, not this middle one containing the variables of u.
So since we've performed this step of a u substitution here, we want to turn
these u values back into x values. I'll start by listing my answers, u equals 9
and u equals 4. Now, we can substitute this value of u with x squared. This
allows us to get the x values that make the original equation true. We simply
just sub each of these for x. Now that we've made the substitution for u, what
do you think the values of x could be? When you think you have the answers,
write it as a solution set here. Use commas in between each response. Good
luck.